Algeria has bid farewell to its days
under president Abdelaziz Bouteflika as
governments
this man led Algeria for almost 20 years
folks his last days they were pretty
crazy something like a cross between
fantasy fiction and an ancient myth on
the one hand we've got this guy both
flare car who cannot communicate
efficiently and he resembles the
decrepit King Theoden from Lord of the
Rings a ruler puppeteered by his
advisers on the other ends we've got a
kind of Algerian version of El Cid
Campea Dora absolutely incapacitated
both flee a car surrounded by his
acolytes who hoped to stick him into a
wheelchair and wheel him into his fifth
presidential term but follow the second
because maybe you don't know who else it
can Theodore is well talking about the
legendary Spanish historical character
that Charlton Heston played in the 1961
movie El Cid your colors are no longer
black until my father is Avenged my
colors would be deepest black then leave
a link in the description below to that
if you want to read a bit more on the
subject
the fact is that this was the last straw
and it kicked off a chain of events both
via car he wouldn't have fifth term but
folks to be honest that's the least of
us thinking that there's democracy in
our Cheerios sort of like thinking that
Nicolas Maduro won the last elections in
Venezuela all fair and square
Venezuela no gracias so leader creo que
la democracia mess fully the math
completely man liberated total continent
americano Algeria is a democracy in name
but it's not an effective democracy what
they do have though is a lot of
questions on the table
what has vote leave comments for
Algeria's history what will happen when
he leaves and are we about to witness
new chapter of the Arab Spring well
today and visual politic we are going to
answer all of these questions but first
a bit of history
the origin
we only need to take a look at our Giri
as most recent history to understands
the enormous power that the army has
always had in this country in the last
60 years Algeria has undergone a
liberation war against the French shake
military dictatorship that ran for more
than two decades and a 10-year civil war
in other words in the last 60 years the
Algerian army has been a key player in
most current affairs and most national
politics but basically if he hadn't
resigned April the 27th 2019 would have
marked the 20th anniversary since the
army candid overpower to boot fair car
in that time he was considered the
consensual president of Algeria two
decades later many people think that
this was Algeria's most stable period
and that over those decades it became
one of the safest countries in the Arab
world however many analysts think that
this is due to stagnation rather than
stability but hold on a second because
before we continue I think we should
answer a fundamental question
just who is abdul aziz boot flyer car
well depois our protagonist was born
eighty-two years ago in under a Moroccan
city near the border with Algeria
his parents were Algerians and at the
age of 19 he decided to join the
National Liberation Army to fight the
French during the war his career
skyrocketed and he soon became part of
Colonel who re booed midians in a circle
who was the main head of state that is
how once the country's independence was
achieved in 1962 mood Flair car was
already a minister even though he was
only 25 years old and shortly after that
when boumedienne himself then Minister
of Defense engineered a coup d'etat
taking a step towards the military
dictatorship our protagonist played a
very very important role you see who re
booed modeun was president of Algeria
until his death in 1978 and the dis side
was Butley a car who was Algeria's
foreign minister during the entire
dictatorship but of course after but--my
attends death Bouteflika suffered the
fate of many people who collaborate or
are a part of a dictatorship he fell
into disgrace he was accused of and
condemned of corruption and his public
image it was absolutely in tatters so he
moved to Europe
of course it didn't take long until he
returned to a very troubled algeria at
that time and we're talking about the
end of the 1980s in the beginning of the
1990s here the Algerian revolution it
was trying to leave behind a
single-party regime and become an
authentic democracy once and for all it
was precisely in this context in 1991
that the first open parliamentary
elections were held in the first rounds
the Islamist party won by a landslide
the second round it didn't even happen
the army annulled all votes before the
Islamists could achieve a sufficient
majority to change the constitution and
turn Algeria into a new Iran then
Algeria began a civil war against
Islamism the result 200,000 deaths
inside of a decade
labor voir
it was then after the Civil War that
Bouteflika is time it really came
see in 1999 the then military presidents
Lea means arrow I'll unexpectedly
resigned and called for presidential
elections so the army didn't want free
elections they saw a boat for the aircar
is the right person to lead Algeria
towards national reconciliation and as
it was said so it was done nothing else
was needed and were basically both
flicka's government managed to end the
civil war he managed to act with a
steady hands even at the worst of
moments and not only that both flare car
opens the country's economy to foreign
investments this made it possible for
gas and oil revenues to sustain the
government's social policies since then
folks Algeria has become a kind of Ron
ta country they took the income from
their oil and gas industry for granted
and defended heavily on that money to
run the country that large part of the
population quickly became accustomed to
subsidies and to the fact that basically
all products were heavily subsidized all
of this allowed motorcar to maintain as
popular support without having to take a
single step towards the country's
effective democratization
we all knew him in the tea Bella
Annabeth
since mode flicka's rise to power that
power it was concentrated increasingly
in the presidential palace this became
so extreme that political institutions
cease to have any value in practice vote
flick ah he was the power the
concentration of power was so great that
when the leader suffered a stroke in
2013 nobody could see an alternative
there was no plan B all the plans for
our G Ria's future included Butley a car
as the country's political leader what
happens is that this stroke led to one
of the most surreal scenarios ever seen
in a country's politics but via car was
left in a wheelchair practically unable
to speak and completely dependent on
others obviously the president couldn't
govern under these conditions however
when presidential elections were held in
nobody thought of an alternative even
though the president couldn't even
address the population during the entire
election campaign he still won the
elections now don't be surprised they
were Algerian democracy is a bit like
that the results are determined even
before the votes are cast and so now you
might be wondering why I mean if the old
leaders not doing it who exactly is
ruling Algeria and this is precisely
where lip of war comes in
see Papua is a French word that means
power so the power or the pouvoir as
they say in Algeria is an expression
that refers to the elites that have
dominated the Algerian Republic since
the country's independence these are
political economic and military elites
that have been unable to agree on a new
president for the last six years so yeah
you could probably see how Algerian
democracy really works in any case not
being able to agree on a candidate
wasn't something that really worried
these elites after all they had brutally
Akkar to maintain their privileges and
control over the country however this
time they made a mistake
the limit since 2014 the drop in oil and
natural gas prices has been a major blow
to the Algerian economy the country's
income decreased by 50 percent and don't
forget that more than half of the
Algerian budget is financed by
hydrocarbon exports basically the books
became so wildly unbalanced that extreme
measures were taken such as this Algeria
bans imports of cellphones furniture
food to curb trade deficit and of course
in addition to these prohibitions many
other goods were taxed with very high
tariffs because of course when our NTA
country loses income well I mean how can
they pay the bills and reality is they
can't so those subsidies they have to
get cut Algerian lawmakers approved
budget calling for hikes in fuel prices
taxes
with the loss of income from the drop in
oil and gas prices Algeria's situation
it became critical you see despite the
government cutting spending by 10
percent per year the public deficit
reached an alarming level 12 percent of
the GDP and of course being unable to
finance many of the subsidies that the
government used to distribute the cost
of living in Algeria has skyrocketed in
the last five years and I think you
could probably now understand the huge
social discontent that's going on in
Algeria Algeria soaring food prices fuel
popular resentment
and as if this wasn't enough Algeria is
a very young population the average age
is under 30 the combination of a lot of
young people and economic stagnation can
be lethal for this type of regime why is
that because if a country is starker in
a crisis it can't create opportunities
for the young people and they have the
strength and vitality to take to the
streets and well that's precisely what
happens for young Algerians there was no
other way to end the regime led by the
mummy he has hopefully a car is
popularly known they aims to ends a
dictatorial and very corrupt regime that
has condemned the country to chronic
stagnation turning it into a country
that has had to get used to news like
this east-west highway 5 billion dollars
of corruption
that is why when on February the 10th
the regime announced Puglia cars
candidacy for a fifth turn in elections
that would of course be rigged it was
the straw that broke the camel's back
six days later on February the 16th 2019
mobilizations against this candidacy and
against the regime again little by
little the protests spread throughout
the country which organ about the
biggest mobilization that Algeria has
experienced since 1999
and there's incredible success just six
weeks after the protests began
bouteflika was forced to resign and
leave power but of course this doesn't
mean that the problems are over for
Algeria
not at all we still need to see if the
elites will accept open elections
without pouting if the opposition can
get organized and prepare a solid
candidacy and if the results of this
process will actually lead to an
effective political transition meanwhile
the country's economy continues to have
many problems to balance the budget the
Margrave country needs to set the oil
price at over $99 Styron price on
asunder 75 and that's not all you see
one of the country's future challenges
is decreasing their dependence on
hydrocarbons but first Algeria needs to
liberalize its economy and favor the
arrival of more foreign investment in
the hydrocarbon sector in order to avoid
production forecasts from not being met
folks algeria is one of the largest
energy producers in africa and it's a
key natural gas supplier to europe but
if there's no investments production
will fall and evidently a fall in
production due to not having invested
enough would seriously aggravate that
country's economic problems here at
visual politic we've already seen this
happen in Venezuela for example because
the investments that the oil sector
needed they were not made you want to
learn more about that we tell you all
about it in this video now algeria is
not venezuelan us obvious but
international companies complain about
the tremendous bureaucracy the
incredible uncertainty and also all the
corruption that plagues the country as
you can see the challenge that algeria
faces in the post vote fear car era is
enormous so what will happen to the
country from now on will the country
achieve its much-needed political and
economic transition or will the elites
of the
bouteflika era maintain their power and
control by putting another president
they trust in to lead the country well
that remains to be seen and we'll keep
you updated about it in any case in a
few years we hope that algeria will
resemble tunisia more than it does egypt
so i really hope you enjoyed that video
if you did please do hit that like
button and don't forget to subscribe
brand new videos also don't forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine also
this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always I'll see you next time